foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
the air and the spare there was no
judgment about it but also no ambiguity
I was a shadow the support the plan b
I was brought into the world in case
something happened to Willie I was
summoned to provide backup distraction
diversion and if necessary a spare pot
OMS you big baby tonight on Piers Morgan
uncensored the world gags and grimaces
as hypocrite Harry's poisonous Memoir
finally hits the shelves it's apparently
the fastest selling non-fiction book
ever but it's in the wrong category
isn't it non-fiction most of it's a
loaded well I won't say family
television but as anger Rises on both
sides of the Atlantic how much longer
can he cling on to his Royal titles
in another interview about today Harry
says his Taliban kills boast which is
part of his healing Journey but as he
actually put our Armed Forces at greater
risk we'll debate that with the man who
killed Osama Bin Laden
that's as Prince William reportedly
claims Harry was brainwashed by his
therapist and is mentally unwell
self-help Superstar Paul McKenna will be
here say how he can heal poor Harry
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored only
day two of my return I'm already utterly
exhausted by Harry
it doesn't stop does it just interview
after interview after series after but
it's just never ending anyways venomous
Memoir spare or spare me as I renamed it
finally hit the shells today between the
copies sold by mistake in Spain the
orders posted early by Amazon the
endless press leagues and the multiple
TV interviews there aren't many
surprises left for viewers but the
reviews are in and they're not great for
poor Harry woke Bible the guardian
Savages it as a flawed attempt to
reclaim the narrative which deals in the
tropes of tabloid storytelling even is
it lambastian the New York Times
normally in spasms of ecstasy when
there's a chance to bash Britain says
there's only so many Revelations of
public and stomach I think we may have
exceeded that judging by the grown in my
guts this evening and the latest opinion
polls showed that almost two-thirds of
britons now have a negative view of a
man who until recently was one of the
most popular Royals in the country is it
a record low I'll be surprised the more
he talks the more we Grimace he's a
transatlantic turn off about as popular
as well a frost bitten todger to quote
him tonight's Harry's on the latest leg
of his Royal trashing tour in America
guzzling Tequilas joking about his
favorite sandwich on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert and with his most grisly
and graphic claims already revealed
today's eager readers are feasting on
well stuff like this
at last someone said it was time for the
concert to begin off you go follow your
father
concert paw impossible to believe
even more impossible while it was
actually happening but I saw it with my
own eyes POG gamely nodding to the beat
and tapping his foot
if you want my future forget my past if
you want to get with me better make it
fast
after on the way out there were more
flashes this time the Spice Girls
weren't there to deflect attention it
was just poor and me
why does he sound like Gordon Ramsay
have you noticed the audio book is very
Gordon Ramsay
but ironically the wannabe which was the
Spice Girls Anthem that's pretty much
what he's become right he's a wannabe
reality star he wants to be a male
Kardashian doesn't he he's now on the
late night talk show circuit in America
guzzling Tequilas and telling stupid
jokes and having the Mickey taken out of
her back corgis he's become just a joke
but he's a senior Royal still an
ambassador for Britain part of one of
the most respected institutions in the
world
now he's just a gossiping gutter snipe
selling out his family to the highest
bidders Harry calls the tabloids in full
disclosure I edited Tablo newspapers
here very proudly for 10 years he calls
tabloid the devil
but it's his smirking face on the cover
of all the U.S tabloids which he's done
interviews with
my story my words the problem is that
Harry's story has more holes than a
trumpet he rails against the tabloids
whilst tossing them lurid stories about
sex drugs frostbitten todgers and family
dramas to sell copies of his book about
mounting older women around the back of
pubs
about his brother being circumcised
he's the poster boy for privacy who's
betrayed the privacy of his closest
Family the truth the real truth not his
my truth is that Harry doesn't have a
problem with the press his problem is
not being able to control the Press
Harry has gambled everything on This
Bitter attempt to bully the media and
the public and his own family into
believing his version of history but
unlike the growing list of media Devils
that he sold his own soul to we're just
not buying it well joining me now as a
journalist and Royal author Tina Brown
talk to you if he's Paula run Adrian and
Richard Tires Plus Sunday Times Royal
editor Roy knicker and dailymail.com
columnist Maureen Callan across the pond
in America so welcome this is probably
the greatest panel ever assembled and
quite rightly too let me start with the
queen of of Royal books the queen nation
of magazine editing as well the queen in
many different uh spheres Tina Brown
I've really wanted you on the show about
this because it's been rumbling on now
for a long time what is your summary of
where we are with Harry
well the interesting part is you know
there's an expression in Psycho you know
therapy which is the extinction burst
right that when sometimes patients sort
of act it all out like throw it all out
and it just that's it it's an Extinction
burst and then they're calm so the
question is this you know is this the
Harry's Extinction burst but the problem
is with him is that he's so much in his
own bubble that he's not thinking about
or caring really about how these bullets
land I mean you know he is right now
like in his Apache helicopter like
firing these you know right but here's
the thing he regarded the Taliban as he
says very unattractively as sort of just
objects things on a chest pieces yeah
but the people he's hurling these
bullets at this time I mean these are
real people right they are his family so
how does he imagine that this Extinction
burst can now be followed with
reconciliation because it's like they've
been left like bleeding on like reeling
and you know helicopters you know would
sort of propellers go in in their face
how can they be ready for he's he's
basically said I'm gonna just like
annihilate you all now I'm ready to
recognize yeah it's to me it's a very
strange well to me it's a complete joke
it's bringing Roya um I mean Roy you're
very plugged in with the Royals and the
and the Palaces what has been the
reaction of the royal family I mean just
the little bit that I know is that
they're utterly staggered by what
they've been reading and hearing uh
deeply hurt and Incredibly angry and in
Prince William's case very very angry
um appears I would say all of the above
um pretty dismayed I think by the level
of detail that Harry's chosen to go into
um and I think you know one of the sort
of ongoing themes here and I've really
felt as I've read the book and he's
extraordinarily personal conversations
with members of his family emerged you
sort of wonder how he might have reacted
if the shoe being on the other foot and
members of his family had you know put
into a book those kind of conversations
the royal family are
pretty cross pretty angry pretty
devastated and upset
um but I think I do really think that
they will still continue to absorb all
of this and keep on and carry on
silently I don't think we're going to
get any kind of big on the record
reaction I think the hope with the royal
family is this you know when Harry's
finally done his last interview whenever
that might be
um this will
burn out and then possibly
reconciliation May begin but that's not
going to happen anytime soon I don't
think I can't imagine it happening at
all this was my family I'd never want to
see that person again it's bringing
Maureen across the pond in America I
mean there's a kind of split view really
about I think younger Americans uh
perhaps have feel a bigger Affinity with
this kind of thing they like the
outpouring of emotion all the rest of it
um but most Americans I've spoken to
over the age of about 30 share my own
revulsion about this constant constant
attack on the royal family by one of
their own
yeah you know peers it's interesting I'm
not seeing really a divide by age group
I think what we're seeing especially in
the aftermath of the Brad B interview
the 60 Minutes interview the Stray hand
interview and now he's on the cover of
people here in the states is an actual
overwhelming backlash to the sheer
number of lies he's been caught telling
you know to see him tell Tom bradby well
we never said the royal family was
racist with a stray face and blame the
British press when we have all spent the
past two years
litigating and relitigating what is
wrong in the house of of Windsor you
know and to do this to allow this light
this odious lie to stand when your
grandfather is on his deathbed when your
grandmother is in ailing Health when
you're talking about Legacy destroying
accusations how no journalist could push
back and say Harry why during any moment
during the past two years did you not
raise your hand and say you know what
media you got it wrong for someone who
loves to tell the media how much they
got it wrong this particular hypocrisy
to me is is beyond I completely agree
with you I want to play the whole clip
in context so that we can judge it for
ourselves this is actually what Meghan
Markle said to Oprah Winfrey
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what about
how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like to hold it hold up there's
several minutes there are several
conversations there's a conversation
with you with Harry
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like oh
and you're not going to tell me who had
the conversation
I think that would be very damaging to
them okay compartmentalize they were
concerned that if you were to
Brown
that that would be a problem are you
saying that
I wasn't able to follow up with why but
that if that's the Assumption you're
making I think that feels like a pretty
safe one
no that's a pretty straightforward
charge of racism against whoever said
that heard it from the horse's mouth
Meghan Markle this is what her husband
Prince Harry said to ITV
in the Oprah interview you accuse
members of your family of racism you
don't even well of the British press
said that
right
I did Megan never mention the races
she said there were troubling comments
about what she was concerned about his
skin color right wouldn't you describe
that as essentially I wouldn't not
having lived within that family
right so to me utter delusion
disingenuousness or maybe outright lies
and I've got a vested interest because I
queried all this at the time and as a
result of me questioning this what may
be a pack of Lies I had to leave my job
a Good Morning Britain and none of this
appears in the book isn't that amazing
this is his life story this was the
biggest thing that has blown up in his
life him and his wife accusing the royal
family of racism and not a word of it
appears in his book nor is there a
single word about the other thing I
challenged which was I did not believe
that Meghan Markle wasn't questioning
her Suicidal Thoughts that's for her to
determine whether she had those or not
but she specifically said she went to
somebody at the palace and asked for
help and was told she couldn't have any
help this is while her husband's on
speed dial to his own therapist to get
help after his brother chins him so none
of this adds up let's bring in Paula
Paula this to me is I I think this is
incredibly serious because I think what
you have here is a retraction
with Weasley words about what we all
heard with our own our own eyes and our
own ears that went around the world for
the next two years this family was
racist and harboring someone in their
midst who as Oprah said there were
concerns that if he were too Brown that
would be a problem are you saying that I
wasn't able to follow up with why but if
that's the Assumption you're making I
think that feels a pretty safe one that
is a charge of racism it's not
unconscious bias it's saying there's a
racist at the palace Pierce there are
just so many issues here that I want to
try and get through with you really
quickly because I know I'm going to be
shouted down no you're not told that I
know I'd love to hear you trying to
explain why why what I've just said is
wrong there's nothing about me trying to
explain it's very easy to explain it's
very easy for a person of color to
explain that he didn't say racism she
didn't say racism the issue was about
the color of the child's skin now I can
tell you that in many many family homes
where there is a person of color the
issue of the child's skin color is going
to come up that is not shocking is that
racism that is not racist the why for
two years why for two years do you see
what's happening no no I'm just asking
you no I'm allowed to ask yourself
if that's not racism why did they allow
despite having a massive PR team two
years of racism headlines to fly against
the family
let me finish answering the first
question
why is it not racism because depending
on the context and it's always about
context it's always about nuances there
is no context it always is about how you
read a situation I could have a
conversation with Richard about the skin
color of our child you could have a
conversation with Richard about the skin
color of our child and it could be in a
completely different we don't know we
don't know because they haven't revealed
exactly hang on what people do know that
Megan felt that it was in a negative
Megan wasn't even there now that doesn't
mean it wasn't even in the room but
she's only talking about her feet and
she said it happened when she was
pregnant Harry said it happened when
they first got together that's a that's
a two-year Gap I I can I didn't believe
it at the time I don't believe it now I
think it's a pack of Lies designed to
denigrate and smear the royal family I'm
sorry I feel very angry on behalf of the
royal family for these lies that were
smeared and now it doesn't even make a
paragraph in his book in Harry's
interview with Tom Bradbury he said that
when William and Kate met with Megan or
just before they met forgive me they had
raised concerns and and he felt that
they were going to be concerned about
the fact that she was the stereotypes
the fact that she was American the fact
that she was an actress and the fact
that she was biracial
why would there be a concern about that
peers let's be frank about this this is
an institution that costs the taxpayer
102 million pounds a year where we have
seen that there have been issues in
relationship
they make more money racism they make
more money
than they cost us and how they tackle
the approach that they have what's
racism you just said there wasn't
anything okay and we know that there is
an issue because Harry's raised it we
know that there's nothing because no
problems
with respect what happens when she
raised it the two people who have raised
the issue of racism what has happened
they have been vilified
it goes in Fulani okay she was the one
who's had the death threats she's the
one who's had shut down her charity yeah
it was legacies and that's got fired
within 24 hours and why why did she need
to get fired well it's not a very good
question if even Prince Harry says it
wasn't racist I'm not quite sure why so
we'll come back to that it's about
education that's what this is going to
be about education keep talking here it
comes down to this there was no racism
that's what we now know from his own
mouth
they allowed the royal family to be
smeared with the charge of racism
Richard to me this is actually really
disgraceful it's appalling and I'm
afraid I completely disagree Paula Megan
deliberately left that interview hanging
there and the couple left it hanging
there for two years but the thing is
here didn't correct it
is
but here's the point no sane or rational
person could behave could write and
could speak as Harry has done he has
betrayed not only his close family his
father his brother he's betrayed The
Wider royal family he's betrayed the
military and he's betrayed the British
people actually it's the greatest of a
trail you know what it's worse than that
I've Tina one of the things I found most
offensive I read it all yesterday
uh was an extraordinary out of nowhere
attack on a matron at Love Grove prep
school where he was a young kid who he
calls basically ugly and greasy didn't
make any of the boys feel horny he then
boasts about mocking her disability she
had a spinal disorder which meant that
she walked in a very uh you know
difficult Manner and he he's to mimic
her a mocker this is a woman called Pat
Jones I saw a couple of journalists who
knew her went to Love Grove saying she
was a old battle act style matron of the
old school but it was very much liked by
kids this is Prince Harry in one of the
biggest selling books ever
taking down this matron you know take
down people that can handle it but a
matron a prep school we don't even know
she's alive or not but the family will
be that in a sense was one of the sort
of I haven't got as far as you got
through it but that really stuck out to
me as a sort of moment of truth of the
hooray Henry that right that Harry was
is the truth or is I mean it's it's a
typical sort of public school boy
snickering demeaning like making fun of
the quote you know old bag who's the The
Matrix a very unattractive moment
actually what fascinates me about this
book is it seems to have had a complete
absence of kind of a tone police sort of
reading it it's so uneven well talk
about mounting a woman around the back
of a pub it's so uneven and I think one
of the big mistakes that he's made in
this book actually is to not have it
edited from the English company it's
been edited from I mean they do
obviously they're edit they anglify it
but they that the actual sort of
creative process was all done sort of
from the American Ghost Writer who's a
very very good writer but has none of
that sensitivity to the sort of houses
in one example I would give we had the
fury Before Christmas of what Jeremy
Clarkson wrote in his column about
Meghan Markle he shouldn't have done it
he conceded he shouldn't have done it
the son apologized for what he did so we
all agree that that was an appropriate
and shouldn't have been done and was
offensive but Harry in his own book
tears into a female newspaper editor at
the time who now actually runs this
company that is in charge of talk TV
says she's a loathsome toad everyone who
knew her was in full agreement she was
an infected pustule on the ass of
humanity plus a bleep excuse for a
journalist I mean he is incensed by any
criticism of his wife or any bad way
that people talk about it and yet he's
prepared to take down this female editor
with that kind of language take down an
innocent matron with the most horrible
language call call Camilla his
stepmother a dangerous villain uh tear
into poor old Kate talk about her kid
crying all this kind of thing you put it
all together for a guy who's who's
married to this supposed feminist the
way he talks about women throughout this
book is pretty appalling it really
required unedited you know the thing
that's interesting about Harry is you
know he goes on and on he's always
complaining about the palace the gray
men in suits actually the gray men in
suits are very often very smart about
keeping him him and everybody else out
of trouble right they see the minds yeah
that they they do see the mines Harry
sitting in Montecito has found what it's
like to not have the palace platform
right the palace platform are fantastic
at sort of generating invitations
Sunshine sacks the pr firm from L.A and
they think this is all great they don't
have any sense of nuance they don't have
a feeling of the cultural uh sort of
fragilities they have no sense of what
the military will think what people will
think it's a really Claude hopping edit
yeah I've got to say I totally agree and
that comes from some of his own books
are superbal is it as you would expect
from somebody
let's keep all the pack here now let's
take a short break and come back and
talk about what should the Royal Family
do should they continue to never explain
never complain which is the palace way
for these things or as some people think
so they come out fighting should Charles
just take his wife being buried uh in
this way by his son should William take
his wife being attacked him this way by
his own brother so they come out on the
attack or debate
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is what Prince Harry said about the
lovegrove matron hat hat the small mousy
frazzled her hair fell greasily into her
always tired eyes Pat had many crosses
to bear the biggest seamed her knees and
spine the latter was crooked the former
chronically stiff we went on mocking her
as she came down the stairs this is the
king of woke isn't it this is my thing
about the white Brigade they're actually
unbelievably unpleasant people they're
unkind not be kind this woman exists she
her name was Pat Jones I have no idea if
she's still alive I'd love to know and
if she is how she feels about being
trashed in this way probably been
talking about having helped take care of
Harry when he was young proudly and this
is how he repays her how do our family
feel about this the guy's a Shameless
disgusting hypocrite
and that's the goal to get a lot tight
about it the way people talk about his
wife quite extraordinary well still with
the Packers go back to Roy and Nick from
the Sunday Times Roya a lot of people
are urging the royal family to hit back
in some way you've already suggested
that they're unlikely to do that but is
there a Tipping Point here I mean if
Harry does just continue to spray gun
the Royals chipping away at the Mystique
of the monarchy causing real damage
particularly in America which of course
this country relies on for the tourism
that comes from the affection for the
royal family could there be a Tipping
Point where William we've already seen
him snap after the Oprah interview
saying this is most definitely not a
racist family could he come out again
and say something do you think
um I think that's what Harry would
probably really want and really like
um but I don't I just don't get a vibe
that that's what they're gonna do I
think you know from all my discussions
I've had with people close to the king
and with William my feeling is they want
to just sort of do the you know uh show
don't tell response and both the king
and William and Kate are out on
maneuvers in the next couple of days
um and you know William will be braced
for people shouting out things at him
but
where we heard him respond to the Oprah
interview he's now the Prince of Wales
he understands sort of a different
position I don't think we will hear him
hit back
um and I think that their view is that
if there is going to be any likelihood
of reconciliation then I know it might
not be something that you would do in
your family appears but um look at the
king is is a father and I think he feels
he doesn't want to cut his son off at
some point that that will be done
privately and not on the record with
interviews and on the record statements
how can they how could they have a
private meeting with somebody who as you
said you've read the book like I have I
was absolutely staggered by the sheer
volume of private conversations he's put
in the public domain even after Prince
Philip's funeral yeah
with Charles and William after that
that's all in the book private text
messages from Kate and so on them he's
put everything out there why would they
trust him as far as I can throw him
no that's the big problem and you know I
I had a piece in before Christmas where
I was told that Harry Megan wanted to
Summit with the royal family and an
apology and accountability and I put
that to uh you know the Royal Family's
people and there was sort of eyebrows
going through the roof because of that
very point you know Netflix had just
come out there is a major trust issue
but I think if there is any sort of Hope
of a Reconciliation they will try try
and and have some sort of mini Rings
behind the scenes but I don't think
there's going to be an on the record
statement or any kind of um heading back
the other thing I'd say is the royal
family always keep a very close eye on
polls right and the you gov polls this
week speak for themselves in terms of
Harry and Megan's popularity and I think
at the end of the day they know that
Americans have their own minds and I
think America would always have a
special relationship with this country
and I was in Boston with William and
Kate when all the Netflix stuff was
exploding and the Americans are still
behind our royal family yeah well I'll
come back to Maureen about that I mean I
would have a summit with Harry but at
the Tower of London
um Maureen
this suggestion that America actually
still remains in London to me it was a
huge moment when the queen died as to
how America might respond to King
Charles they've all watched the crown
they all may have a jaundice view from
that series about what he's like they
may not have the affection and love that
they have for the queen for example so
it's been a big moment I think for us
here as to how America responds do you
share that feeling that actually the
love is still there for the royal family
for the monarchy
oh a hundred percent peers I mean I
think the more that Harry and Megan
reveal themselves to be sort of the
the cretiness individuals they are you
know when you talked about Pat the
matron at lud Grove you know that
passage you know had he at at all
expressed remorse for being such a
horrible little kid that would have
turned it around you know but he seems
to really Revel in cruelty and one of
the details in the book that struck me
most that I thought was so heartless was
against his own father Charles who we
Americans know of his boarding school
experience through the crown
and he writes about Charles still
carrying his worn childhood teddy bear
with him yeah as a sort of emotional
support because he is still so wounded
from his childhood bullying and I can
just tell you I mean I wrote about this
and the reader response we got the the
Charles Rose in estimation
with that detail that endeared him to
people yeah and Harry is just falling
further and further out of favor he
truly is digging his own grave I don't
see why the Royals would interfere with
that I mean Richard the big question now
is the coronation is coming up in May I
I don't think they should be allowed
anywhere near the coronation because not
only is Charles getting crowned but so
is his Queen consort Camilla who Harry's
just shredded in his book but the
reality is because the royal family have
got to maintain the moral High Ground
you talked about it would you have them
at the coronation I think they've got to
be invited why because because that's
the moral High Ground that's the
Mystique that's the magic that's the the
ultimate quality of what we're talking
about the royal family so yes they
should be invited but frankly behind the
scenes it should be made very clear that
they shouldn't attend but but the Family
itself has to maintain the moral high on
and frankly like a candle let the couple
just burn themselves out Paula I mean my
question which I think Anderson Cooper
with CNN asked Harry if you hated all so
much the institution the fact why do you
want to keep your titles which attach
you to this just go and be yourself well
that wouldn't make any difference was
his response actually it makes a lot of
difference financially to be able to
call themselves a Duke and Duchess of
Sussex and to turn up at things like the
coronation and the Jubilee parades and
so on of course that's their currency
without that what are they just a pair
of quacks in Montecito should I tell you
who they are
they are the people who have identified
that this great institution has problems
and that this great institution is not
facing is not confronting it's talking
about racism again we're talking about
racism
we're talking about unconscious bias
we're talking about ignorance domestic
abuse well we heard about the the fight
didn't we very pushing him into a dog
with William the bloke went to a war in
Afghanistan squealing about having his
necklace broken and shoved in a dolly
part about mental health issues okay
how much these two sizes okay these two
have a foundation website called
archerwell it says it's about compassion
that is the Bedrock of what they stand
for they disowned all of her family
apart from the mother the father lives
70 miles away he's never met his
grandchildren never met Harry hang on
trying to sell something
big mistake for which he's apologized
many times so he's allowed to make a
mistake let me finish they've disowned
him and all of her other markers they've
all been disowned now all of his family
got rid of all then as well where's the
compassion in anything he said he didn't
write this book to hurt and harm them
all he's done in the book is hurt and
harm them the guy wouldn't know to spell
compassion he used to compassion what
Madonna is to growing old gracefully
right honestly he is he is I'm sorry and
this idea that somehow we've got
domestic abuse because William rightly
chinned him over being so insulting to
his wife or that we should care about
their mental health when they don't give
us stuff about the mental health of all
the royal family they've been trashing
Tina final world I've answered the
question but Tina I respect you so too I
mean look it it it's it's the hypocrisy
that makes me puke yeah but I don't I
think they should be invited to the
coronation yes I do actually because I
think that you know they have as you
said Richard they have to take The High
Ground they have to take the
multi-generational Chinese Outlook to
this situation I feel that actually
between the lines Harry's lobbying like
mad to get back into the action I mean
of course the fact that he is didn't
mention anything about the Oprah the
whole racism thing in the book obviously
he has been told you across the red line
if there's any more of this Harry you're
out or it simply didn't happen the way
they said it I think he's trying to get
back in the fact that he praised Susan
Hussey what was that about yeah that was
a complete bone that he was because he's
a total hypocrite that's not the
behavior of a rational person like that
well I'm going to discuss that with Paul
McKenna a little later he's an expert in
you know that kind of behavior what is
it all about as Harry lost his marbles
we'll talk about that it's been a great
pack thank you very much to Maureen to
Roya Tina Paul and Richard probably the
greatest pack assembled in World hundred
three Israel so thank you coming next on
to posting about his Taliban kills in
Afghanistan as Harry put a Target
although it's his back and his band is
back but they're all family facts and
his former military colleagues back
after break with the man who shot and
killed Osama Bin Laden
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
well Harry's decision to reveal a number
of Taliban chess pieces he killed as an
Apache pilot in Afghanistan The
Condemned as a betrayal of the armed
forces his reminder in his own words
I could always say precisely how many
enemy combatants I killed
and I felt it vital never to shy away
from that number
among the many things I learned in the
Army accountability was near the top of
the list
so
my number
25.
it wasn't a number that gave me any
satisfaction
but neither was it a number that made me
feel ashamed
on joining the studio by hanif khadir
who's a consultant on counter-terrorism
and a former member of al-Qaeda the
terror group also joining us is former
U.S Navy SEAL and the man who shot Osama
Bin Laden Robert Neal and Colonel
Richard Kent the former commander in
Afghanistan for the British Armed Forces
so welcome to all of you hanif Kadir
you're a former extremist at the start
really of Al qaeda's operations in
Afghanistan after George Bush declared
the war on terror but you quickly
renounced them after seeing what they
did to civilians and you've become now
an expert in counter-terrorism and how
to tackle this what impact do you think
Harry's comments will have had
well I think firstly coming from a
senior member of the royal family he
hasn't got the combination of qualities
that one should expect dignity honor
courage courtesy Justice and compassion
and his his statements that he's made
Pretty Reckless and damaging not only
have they painted a a bigger bullseye on
the British Armed Forces but anything to
do with the institution but also his own
family as well and I think the statement
that's come out of Afghanistan so far
from anasakani I mean it's it's pretty
modest but we can expect that he's
allowed the narrative to move a few more
notches up where we've been trying to
counter that extremist narrative over
the years
um and it's been pretty difficult
the the the the UK narrative well let's
say The British military native has been
quite effective so far but what have you
gone and done is just gone and
annihilated it well let me bring in uh
Colonel Ken I mean you you operated in
in Afghanistan one of the commanders
there Harry has told People magazine
it's a duty a job a service to our
country I've done all I could be the
best soldier I could but truly no right
or wrong way to try and navigate these
feelings but I know from my own healing
Journey that Silence has been the least
effective remedy expressing and
detailing my experience is how I chose
to deal with it in the hopes it would
help others what's your reaction to that
justification
well I think I think he's actually in
the comments he's made I I don't
personally have a huge problem with him
spelling out the numbers he's killed
everyone knows he was a a crew member of
an Apache attack helicopter whose job
was to kill the enemy I don't have an
issue with that the issue I have is with
the way he's described British army
training to teach people like him that
uh the Taliban and the enemy are less
than human they're just chess pieces to
be swept off the board which is
dangerous because it's wrong that's not
the way the British army is taught and
uh it also it shows the Army in a in a
way that I think feeds straight into
jihadist propaganda they'll use that
they already have used it to show the
lack of humanity of the British forces
the way the British forces did not treat
fighters in Afghanistan as human beings
and and it will lead I think to
radicalization and possibly to inciting
Taliban and other jihadists to carry out
attacks against British people here in
this country and elsewhere in the world
well Rob O'Neill I mean there's been a
lot of backlash to this from the British
Armed Forces certainly almost everyone
I've seen has shared the view of Colonel
Kent that he shouldn't have gone down
this Avenue we know you as the man who
heroically shot and killed the world's
worst terrorist Osama Bin Laden and
thank you again for doing that
um we know that because you wrote about
it yourself in a book
um a great book and you talk about other
kills as well in there do you
intrinsically have any problem with what
Harry has said here
no I don't have a problem with it at all
Pierce if he goes through the proper
channels which I hope he did
um then there's not there's nothing
wrong with talking about what happened
to him war and it's just to know as far
as the history of War goes and for
future Generations as long as it's the
truth and if you're telling the truth
you don't even remember anything else
having said uh they're like chess pieces
I think that's giving them a compliment
because it's not that complex the man's
flying on Apache helicopter a kill
helicopter and he's giving him a little
bit of credit I mean it's not like
islamists are going to like us any less
or want to kill us more because of
something Prince Harry said and it's you
know the connies are saying it the
connies of Benji hotties and criminals
traffickers and drug pushers since since
the Russians invaded so it's not like
they're great people either
um yeah I mean he said what he said and
I think he was he was nice about it it
was up to me and they were actually
terrorists I wish he would have killed
more I mean somebody said that there's a
big difference between a British soldier
or someone like you for example killing
a hundred Taliban and a member of the
royal family killing one that the
amplification of the fact he's a member
of the royal family doing this does put
a bigger security risk Target against
the royal family against him and his
family now in California and potentially
against British troops
because of who he is well like I was
saying I mean there's there's been a
Target on them forever and there will be
and you know it's not like if he if he'd
said nothing they could put their heads
in the sand and pretend they're not
targets they are targets I hope their
security is uh you know on point I hope
you know they're fine but the
realization there are people that are
going to hate him and me and you just
the same you know as always and you know
they're going to prop this up they're
putting Afghanistan back on the map and
Hillman province which is dangerous on
the map but you know he said what he
said and I'm glad he said it and and um
you know we can learn from what people
did there if you had had a spa have you
got any brothers I I don't know the
answer to that question
yeah I've got an older brother and as
far as getting beat up uh
if your older brother had knocked you
into a dog bowl and broken your necklace
would you have ever put that into the
public domain or would you have felt
that that would be probably the most
shameful admission you could ever make
well being a younger brother like I said
I always I tell my brother he was the
reason I joined the Navy just so I come
back and kick his butt um and you know
it all depends on the size of the
contract if I need to rub some dirt on
my brother to get some cash who knows
what do you make it Rob of this I mean
you're one of the most famous guys in
America what do you make of this uh
Harry and Megan ongoing saga do you care
well you know I am married and Jessica
loves it so I hear about I had to tell
her the other day look Jessica as much
as I love to talk to you about this I'm
out of talking points I don't care
enough to do it I mean I I you know I
have never met uh either one of them and
I wish them the best uh it is
entertaining once in a while but I just
can't get into it that much when there's
uh other things in life that are more
important to me do you ever think that
maybe if if King George III had not been
so useless we could have still had a
royal family in America possibly even
King peers by now
you know yeah King Pierce I tell you
what if we want to make uh campaign
posters for 2024 put me on there with
you buddy
I think I could have done a good job on
the throne of America uh Robin Hill uh
great to talk to you Colonel Kemp thank
you very much uh hanif khalir appreciate
you coming in for your perspective well
coming up next did anyone heal tormented
Harry if anyone can uh Paul McKenna
hypnotist and behavioral scientist will
join me to discuss it is he healable the
big question
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well welcome back uh Prince Harry
reveals he called his therapist to
mentioned after being chined by Brother
William William for his bar reportedly
says therapy brainwashed his brother
well Paul McKenna hypnotist and author
more than 20 books including his latest
which is freedom from anxiety very
timely I think things are Harry's epic
over sharing has done wonders for mental
health joins me now Welcome To You Paul
um what are you making this what state
is Harry in to be doing all this well
clearly the therapy is doing isn't
working he's doing a number of different
things he does something called EMDR eye
movement desensitization reprogramming
this um it works it absolutely works for
some people
um but the reason I don't use that is
because I find that it doesn't stick and
so that's just my personal finding plus
also he's doing talking therapies and
again they work for a lot of people for
getting things off your chest it's good
but after you've done that you need to
compartmentalize it post-rationalize it
if you just keep going over it again and
again and again and that's the tendency
with talking therapies you know I'm I
meet people who say you know they've
been in therapy for 10 years and they'll
say they'll explain like a shrink
they'll say I've got a load of un you
know resolved anger with my father but
it hasn't made any difference to how
they feel so you know if you look at him
sadly I think he's um he's very upset
well I mean that's the thing to me is he
keeps talking about how happy he now is
I don't get a sense of anyone less happy
than Harry right now he just looks
miserable and angry and bitter and
resentful and completely bemused why his
constant attacks on his family would
mean they don't want to talk to him yeah
well you see he'd be telling himself
because let me put it like this um
basically the majority of people uh they
don't wake up each day and think how can
I hurt people or upset people you know
they they actually think that they're
well-intentioned and so he'll be saying
to himself his narrative will be but
he's been victimized he's been you know
he's the been wronged Etc and uh
everything that's going on right now
plays into that he talks a lot about his
mother and obviously he goes without
saying it was an appalling thing to
happen to him when he was just 12 years
old but he's not the only person to lose
a parent when he was young and he's now
heading towards 40 and he's still going
on and on and on about it again I just
see slight alarm Bells yeah with that
that he can't seem to let anything go
and he's constantly recycling all these
things in his mind whereas people I know
lost parents young they do manage to
move on they compartmentalize it like
you said yes I mean so I've worked a lot
with War veterans in the last few years
with PTSD and some people we say the
past is always present they literally as
you say reliving it they're still in
Iraq or they're still on a battlefield
and they think about it all the time and
it goes on in their minds so they're a
prisoner if you like of their own
um their own thinking a lot of people
are able the ones that are functional
they can put it to one side they can
step out of it and they can you know see
it as those it was something that
happened a long time ago do you see
Harry as being intrinsically dysfunction
at the moment in his behavior
um he's functioning in as much as he's
able to go to work and do things and
he's you know family man but you what
you just said is when I see him
interview he seems sad and he seems
angry and you know those are not great
places to live I mean we all have to
feel sad and angry at certain times in
our life and you know he has been
through a terrible trauma with the loss
of his mother you know and and it's
amazing we all have a mechanism within
us to get over things and some people
get over things quickly and other people
can can take years well his own brother
has taken a very different path William
he went through the same yes misery and
hell he had to do the same thing that
Harry did yeah he's only three years
older he's managed yes to go through it
in a much better way I would think yeah
sometimes you find this with the
brothers or sisters they can both go
through a traumatic incident and one of
the siblings is fine you know they just
get on with life and the other and why
is that well again it's to do with the
way that they processed it in their mind
if one is compartmentalized it and they
go it's terrible but I'm able to put it
aside and these are the techniques that
I use with people you know I'm not a fan
of the well I don't use talking
therapies with people very much where
sit and ask them about their past what I
get them to do is to to transform the
way they think about it recode it would
you if you were here now with Harry what
have you had a few hours with him what
would you do with it well the first
thing is I look with anybody I need to
assess them I need to find out what I do
is I step into their perspective and I
try and see the world through their eyes
so I would try and see how he's
upsetting himself what is he saying to
himself all day long you know that um
that these people are against him or
that's a bad thing or or is he picturing
over and over again movies of unhappy
times and telling himself you know he
can't get over it so those are the kind
of things that people that are
constantly distressed do and then what I
would do is I would get him to step out
of those memories and step into Happy
ones I get them to think about the
future again think about all the kind of
goods I don't think he's getting that I
think that his wife Megan's a bit like
him they trade off his victim at all the
time his sense of being victims and it's
it's wrecking their lives even it's not
making them happy or free no I think the
thing with you know with being we've
been victimized is you get to feel
virtuous right to feel Superior and you
know nowadays um some people wear it
like a bag yes it's a badge of honor
it's like something to be proud of I'm a
victim
um
anxiety generally I've noticed I've got
three sons in my 20s yeah uh so I see a
lot of young people a lot around them
their friends and so on a lot of the
younger ones have got a lot of anxiety
issues yeah is it as simple as social
media which could be great can also just
hurl at young people particularly things
like Instagram and some constant imagery
either of a life that they can't have or
a really disturbing imagery which
flashes around social media which you
wouldn't have never seen 30 years ago
yes is it a combination of these
absolutely it's totally a combination of
that and you know the other thing is
that um as we were talking in the break
you know if there was say an incident um
you know where someone gets attacked by
a crocodile it's on TV it's a you know
but it might or might not be nowadays
you've got constant flow of images of
negative things all day long and also
all these people with you know filters
on who look so perfect and you're
supposed to be as good as them so it
makes you feel inferior I mean we
basically appear as we've come out of a
of a biological pandemic we're in a site
psychological one right now yes and and
what advice do you give just quickly to
young kids who are feeling very anxious
what's the best advice well um read the
book get my book and also download the
techniques but you know if people want
to use the technique of mine for free
I've put a load of my chances up on my
YouTube channel they could watch them
there and then decide if it's for them
or not you know what good advice read
the book Freedom from anxiety Paul
McKenna you've been writing great stuff
about all these kind of things for many
years great to see you thank you I hope
the book does really well thanks very
much that's it from me what are you up
to Keep It Uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign